[Musica]
da bambina amavo le cartine geografiche
gli atlanti e mappamondi ve li ricordate
quelli che li accende vi è da il mondo
da fisico con quei bei colori rilassanti
dei verdi dei marroni dei blu si
trasformava in politico e ricordo che mi
piaceva a fare un gioco mi piaceva farlo
ruotare e attendere il punto in cui si
sarebbe fermato e quel punto era il
luogo dove mi sarebbe piaciuto via
giardia giare virtualmente mi ricordo
anche che mi domandavo chi mai avesse
creato i confini quando appariva il
mondo politico perché li vedevo come
delle costruzioni come dei limiti
studiando la storia dirà la verità poi
qualche concetto melo melo sono chiarita
però sono rimasti sempre un cruccio che
mi infastidiva nella nella mia mente e
crescendo forse ho capito anche perché
perché ho capito che ci sono dei confini
che non ci sono sono solo nelle mappe ma
che sono nella nostra mente e peggio
ancora nel nostro cuore sono le nostre
credenze le nostre convinzioni i nostri
pregiudizi che a volte ci permettono non
ci permettono di prendere in mano la
nostra vita e di realizzare i progetti
che desideriamo ricordano anche che
questi confini
a volte sono tanto talmente forti che mi
fanno ci fanno pensare che 39 13 anni
per una vita non siano sufficienti per
prendere delle decisioni forte forti
responsabili e 40 siano troppi
per avere il coraggio di amare ancora un
po
io proprio a 40 anni viveva una vita
tranquilla
un matrimonio felice due figli
adolescenti 9 e 13 anni
l'unico rischio poteva essere appunto
l'adolescenza quell'età che tutti i
genitori vorrebbero vorrebbero saltare
ap di paris è possibile un lavoro che mi
appassionava la famiglia bene al centro
delle mie delle mie priorità
quindi direi vivevo una vita tutto
sommato tranquilla in un ambiente
protetto e privilegiato ma perché è
privilegiato perché sono nata e
cresciuta in una famiglia impresa in una
famiglia in cui il lavoro è vita e la
vita e lavoro una famiglia nella quale
oltre ai valori fondamentali per
intenderci perché forse meglio anche
intenderci a volte sui sui valori quelli
dei dieci comandamenti acoli ci sono un
po tutti mi sono sempre stati insegnati
anche degli degli atteggiamenti che
hanno fatto di me la persona che sono
diventata ho visto è sempre i miei
genitori affrontare la vita con
generosità la generosità che non è solo
quella del portafoglio la generosità del
tempo e delle idee e ho capito
guardandoli che la generosità portava
con sé si portava con sé la curiosità el
apertura mentale
ho visto i miei genitori assumersi
sempre delle responsabilità di portare a
termine ciò che facevano
io ho visto vivere una vita coraggiosa
ho visto assumersi dei rischi li ho
visti assumersi dei rischi perché
ricordo si diceva sempre che che le
opportunità sono sempre maggiori dei
rischi che si possono correre
ricordo che si diceva anche che i numeri
non mentono mai
ma i numeri non decidono che a volte per
decidere
serve altro serve anche il cuore ecco
questo è il contesto in cui vivevo
questo è l'ambiente che ho respirato
tutti i giorni e che mi ha fatto
diventare la persona che sono che mi ha
fatto interpretare il mio ruolo di
moglie e di madre ed imprenditrice e ne
vado fiera
e sono anche grata ai miei genitori alla
mia famiglia di questa opportunità che
mi hanno dato
è questo il contesto in cui nel 2006 mi
trovavo in yara che di lì a qualche anno
mi sarei dovuto assumere delle
responsabilità e come bagnara
soprattutto che di lì a qualche mese
sarei diventata madre per la terza volta
non di utero ma di cuore
l'affido di un minore non accompagnato
è una procedura relativamente semplice
almeno nel 2006 lo era per me per noi lo
stato pochi incontri una manifestazione
di interesse
tre incontri con gli assistenti sociali
un colloquio col dire con il direttore
della comunità per minori e in pochi
mesi avevamo il decreto di affido
ma oggi non sono qui per raccontarvi per
spiegarvi qual è il formalismo della
procedura ma sono qui per farvi capire è
come è nata l'idea come germogliata
l'idea e soprattutto quali sono state le
intensità emotive che ha portato questo
progetto di vita nella nostra famiglia
l'idea è nata da un incontro come sempre
alle opportunità nella vita
nascono dalle dalle relazioni è nata da
un invitammo incontro di abi che entrava
nella nostra famiglia come compagno di
scuola compagna di scuola di nostro
figlio pier luca che in terza media per
fare i compiti per qualche momento di
svago e ricordo che mi colpirono fin da
subito i suoi occhi neri e luminosi il
suo sorriso così aperto così dolce
questo riso che ti fa pensare che non
voglio che non voleva essere solo ospite
ma anche parte integrante di una
comunità
ma ciò che veramente ci ha colpito che
ci ha portato a prendere questa
decisione così così impegnativa è stato
il suo coraggio la sua determinazione la
sua volontà di apprendere di apprendere
la lingua italiana la nostra cultura di
di conoscere quello che non ha avuto
aveva avuto l'opportunità di apprendere
prima
ed è proprio per questo che da questi da
questi caratteristiche che essa è nata
la scintilla di questa di questa storia
di questa nostra storia
prima in me e poi nella mia famiglia
perché sapete l'affido non è una
questione privata è una questione che
coinvolge tutti coinvolge i famigliari
coinvolge gli amici coinvolge la
comunità nella quale si vive il primo
ovviamente a con cui ho condiviso questo
questa mia idea è stato mio marito fabio
che mia devo dire subito assecondata
amorevolmente ha accennato sia qualche
ai rischi che potevamo andare incontro
ricordo che mi mi diceva abbiamo ci
troveremo con tre adolescenti
ci saranno delle difficoltà però capivo
anche che man mano che esprimeva queste
sue preoccupazioni
il dubbio svanivano e soprattutto aveva
compreso da solo senza il mio aiuto in
quel caso che questa nuova esperienza di
geni di genitorialità ci avrebbe fatto
diventare una famiglia migliore e una
coppia più solida
le opportunità sono sempre superiori ai
rischi che correremo questa era una
frase che mi ritornava come un mantra è
che ho utilizzato proprio per perché mi
sembrava che condensasse tutto rispetto
questa decisione rispetto questa
decisione e ci permetteva di superare i
limiti e le difficoltà che vedevamo nel
presente ed è quella frase che ho
utilizzato anche con i nostri figli per
luca annachiara che allora avevano 9 13
anni per spiegare loro il perché
volevamo affrontare questa esperienza e
soprattutto per convincerli che era
un'opportunità migliore anche per loro
li abbiamo abbiamo parlato loro una sera
dopo cena prima di quel giugno del 2006
e abbiamo comunicato loro che sarebbe
venuto a vivere a vivere da noi e ma che
volevamo che anche loro ne fossero
convinti anche loro ne furono anche loro
capissero quali erano le decisioni le
motivazioni che ci portavano a questa a
questa scelta e soprattutto ci
aiutassero a vivere questa esperienza a
x abdul
poche parole invece semplici ed
affettuose
perché mi premeva a fargli fargli
comprendere qual era la differenza tra
vivere in una comunità di vivere in una
famiglia ad un ricordo che gli dicevo
vivere in una comunità rispetto a una
famiglia in una famiglia ci sono oltre
che le regole da rispettare
ci sono anche le emozioni da vivere
ci sono i momenti belli e momenti brutti
e li vivremo insieme cercando di
superarli
il suo italiano allora non era perfetto
come lo è oggi
e quindi perdersi in argomentazioni
complicate mi sembrava veramente inutile
c'era una vita ad affrontare c'era
qualcosa di bello da costruire ed era
più importante iniziare a viverlo
ed è stato proprio così che nel 30
giugno del 2006 abbia entrato nella
nostra famiglia non non c'erano più
compiti da fare però la scuola era
finita
c'era una vita da costruire e con la
consapevolezza che non era una strada
senza ritorno che potevamo sbagliare
potevamo fallire ma che tutti avevamo ci
stavamo impegnando per raggiungere
questo bellissimo traguardo di
esperienza di vita
c'erano molti confini però da superare
ricordo che le domande erano ma sei
sicura con la vita che hai non s'è mai a
casa hai già due figli maschio e femmina
differenza culturale c'è mai pensato
queste erano le domande che mi venivano
poste oppure se non mi venivano poste le
leggeva negli occhi dei miei
interlocutori e normalmente non
rispondevo queste domande perché mi
sembrava che non ci fosse non ci fosse
bisogno di di argomentare non c'era
bisogno di una risposta logica in quel
momento c'era bisogno di credere in un
progetto è crederci con il cuore andare
oltre
usare non usare le parole ma usare i
sentimenti e quindi rispondevo con un
sorriso lo faccio spesso quando quando
le parole non servono
e andato tutto bene no non tutto
non tutto ci sono stati dei momenti di
difficoltà ci sono state delle
incomprensioni che abbiamo superato
insieme e con la voglia di vivere giorno
dopo giorno questa esperienza ci sono
state incomprensioni e ci sono tuttora
oggi il nostro rapporto ovviamente ad
adulti alla pari ma c'è sempre la stessa
consapevolezza che questa esperienza ha
cambiato per sempre la nostra dieta
ci sono state anche delle difficoltà
perché comunque entrare nell'intimità di
una famiglia e e togliersi le armature
che ci costruiamo nel corso della nostra
vita non è facile ma l'abbiamo fatto
l'abbiamo fatto tra una verifica tra un
giorno di vacanza tra un momento di
difficoltà l'abbiamo fatto con l'umiltà
e la voglia di cominciare di
ricominciare sempre e questo e questo ci
ha ci ha premiati e ci ha dato come
risultato una famiglia migliore
c'è una fotografia che che ci
rappresenta e che credo sia quella che
noi più amiamo e più ci si ricorda
questa esperienza quando abdoul è
entrato nella nostra famiglia
molti mi dicevano ma che ragazzo
fortunato
io mi sono sempre domandata ma può
essere che sia stato fortunato forse è
il caso di chiederlo eventualmente a lui
io so solo una cosa
so che quando è entrato a casa nostra
pensavamo di essere noi a salvare lui
invece alla fine abbiamo scoperto è
stato lui a salvare noi dai pregiudizi
dall indifferenza e dall'egoismo e
guardate i confini tra chi salva ed è
salvato sono sottilissimi e se siamo
consapevoli di questo saremo anche molto
più tolleranti più aperti e più
inclusivi grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]